Manganese is actually a much more interesting metal than you might
expect. I should say element perhaps the metal.
So first thing we need to do is like the Bunsen. So there we are.
Okay.
And then what we've got inside the boiling tube is actually potassium
manganese.
One of the transition metals and the row of transition metals
stretches all the way from scandium over here to
zinc over there.
What makes manganese particularly interesting is that it is in the middle of
this transition group.
There are 10 transition metals from scandium to zinc
and manganese is number five.
The reason that 10 is because each of them has a certain
number of D electrons. One for scandium 10 for zinc.
So manganese in the middle has five and five.
If you're a mathematician, you will notice half 10.
So it has exactly half the number of D electrons that can be
accommodated in the shell.
All I've gone and done is just popped a couple of spatulas of potassium from
Andre into the Boyd in shape. And as you can see from the college, very,
very dark, almost black, uh,
possibly a dark green. So that's in there.
But let's begin just having looked at the metal itself.
This is a bottle of manganese that Neil has lent us and
Brady promised that we wouldn't break it.
Don't tell anyone, but I dropped it and a bit has fallen out at the bottom.
He broke it, you broke it. It was going to be very angry.
Anyway, let's look at the metal.
So you can see the metal is in this particular form is coming
sheets, but has this rather bubbly feature on the
surface?
This is the top of wherever the metals and it's been broken up.
What is also interesting that I've got magnet here and you can see
it's not magnetic at all and you
can't pick it up. Now. You can also,
why is it interesting if something's not magnetic?
Lots of things are not magnetic.
And the reason that's interesting is if you look at it souls,
so this is a salt of manganese.
The label is not very good, but it's manganese sulfate.
[inaudible] the first thing that you notice is that it is almost white.
It's very slightly pink.
And this is surprising because especially in your first
chemistry lessons,
they say the characteristic of the salt of transition
metals is that they're colored and here's manganese sulfate.
Almost remember that manganese metal is not magnetic.
Let's take the same magnet into the sulfate,
push it down.
So you can see that the salt sticks to the magnet.
Now, I think that's extraordinary.
Normally you don't expect salts to be magnetic,
and it's even more surprising if the metal is not magnetic,
but that's all it is.
Of the safety flame into the hot blue flame get so that
it's at the tip of the flame. It's nice and hot there.
Ah, you see a movement there, perfect that movement there.
All we can see going right the way up the tube,
and that's dropping back down again and what's happened there in the heat.
We've changed the oxidation state of the manganese to plus
six.
So it's now K to M N O four.
You're also getting oxygen,
which is why you saw that movement of the powder as the gas is being liberated.
It shots up the tube and you're getting manganese dioxide there.
And the reason why the salt is magnetic is because it has
five electrons, these five electrons in the D cell.
And they so-called, unpaired,
they're each in a different volume of space around the atom.
So each of them has a strong magnetic effect. And with all five of them,
it's really magnetic.
And the fact that the material has no color is
also associated with these five electrons.
If you drop solution of manganese sulfate,
which is also colorless into sodium hydroxide solution,
you get a precipitate of hydroxide.
And because there is air dissolved in the sodium hydroxide,
the oxygen removes one of the electrons from the manganese.
So it now is so-called manganese three,
which has only four electrons and it's nice Brown color.
So you suddenly get this color change.
This was one of the first experiments I did in my second year of university in a
practical class. They didn't tell us what was happening. We had to explain it.
And so now we need to make sure all of it is being converted
to plus six oxidation States.
So I'm going to make sure it stays in that flame for just that bit longer.
Really famous compounded manganese is potassium permanganates,
which is a purple color potassium per blank.
The date is K M a new fall. In fact,
in the MNO four minus the permanganate iron manganese
has no D electrons at all.
They've all gone to the oxygen and there's very bright color is because the
light makes one, the electrons jump back to the manganese.
So you get this very intense color, which is very bright.
Even the small amount of the material causes a lot of color.
And if you drop just a few tiny crystals of permanganates into water,
you can see this beautiful purple color spreading out.
I persuaded Sam to repeat one of the earliest
experiments. I did myself after reading about it in the book,
heating potassium permanganates.
And so apart from that movement of the powder up and down the tube,
it doesn't look like anything else is really happening.
I did this when I was 14 or 15,
Sam is using a nice boiling tube.
I used a metal spoon and a gas stove.
We're going to put it into this, uh, centered funnel.
That's sort of top of the conical flask.
And then I'm going to add some concentrated alkaline to it.
And when you hit the permanganate up,
there is a sort of small puff of gas, but nothing very exciting,
but then you make so-called potassium manganese that
K2 MNO four,
which is bright green.
If you put it in alkalized solution.
So same if she's done,
what I suggested has poured the solid out into a
filter and then poured over it some
strong alkali,
and you should see this really nice dark green color solution coming through.
Thank you. See that normally,
if you put potassium manganese in solution, or you just in water,
we'd go nice purple color. But here, because you've got K2 MN Oh four, um,
it's actually giving you a lovely green color.
But it's a, not a very stable compound.
And if you add acid to the solution,
it decomposes very quickly.
And so you get permanganates back again, plus a precipitate,
which you may or may not be able to see of manganese dioxide,
which is Brown solid. Now,
when I did this experiment as a school boy in the kitchen,
I didn't know all of this chemistry and my sister's clothes were on the
draining board of the sink. They were being washed.
And I'm just saying to say,
and I didn't notice that some of the [inaudible] or magnate got onto my
sister's clothes and Brown spots appeared all over it.
And it was not very popular with my parents. What were you punished?
I can't remember. I think I was forgiving in the interests of science.
[Inaudible].
13,487. Jacqueline has that.
I feel like I should. You should.
That is the biggest Brady number that appears in the first 1 million desperate
places of PI.
Right?